longtime viewer we should cap TV do you
guys have any wisdom principles about
how to take the greatest risk and turn
them into rewards yeah maybe I'll go
first Devon I think the greatest risk
and this is sometimes actually in life
you know I've been shocked when there's
either personal tragedy might I talked
about my dad's business before this is
when I was growing up as a kid you know
my dad got sick and the reality of that
is he couldn't run the business but
because of that we never realized at the
time but from that adversity that was a
great opportunity for us as kids just go
and get jobs and start businesses and
and that was a catalyst for my
entrepreneurial spirit and I know guys
who have been fired and gals a bit fajr
and that's been the trigger point for
them starting their own business and
they've never looked back so I think you
know Rishi in terms of the question
you've got to really look at the biggest
risk is you know ultimately if you get
fired and if you've got no job no income
you got more get you got a family that's
when you're really exposed but it's it's
the spirit of positivity and optimism to
know that you you've got so much to give
back and you've got so much energy and
passion to think of a gap in the market
I think of a product or service that's
going to be kind of a world beater and
just go out there and create it I love
it and I mean the thing can relate to
the quotes that you started off as well
the greatest risk is not betting on
yourself like the greatest risk is you
know putting your hands putting your
future into somebody else's hands and
thinking you're going to be at that same
job for the next 40 years it's you know
it's not going to happen anymore and so
it's not risky as much anymore to bet on
yourself it's never been easier to start
a company and you don't have to go in
full time at the start they learn the
market do it part time get your side
hustle on you don't have to cash in your
tyerman savings and you know mortgage
the house to the max because I'd also
shortens your one way because then you
only have like two months to make this
work and often it takes a lot longer
where if you can
still have whatever is making you money
and then on the side start your business
get it growing get some cash flow coming
in and then once you have it to the
point where you can quit you're not
making tons of money but you have enough
to pay the internet and feed yourself
and the family then now you know when
you go full time on your business you're
able to spend a lot more time to
obviously and continue to grow so I
don't know that you have to go out and
take massive risks but the greatest risk
of all is not not doing anything so like
I have this idea and then you never act
on it because you think it's too scary
and then you know you're 90 looking back
in your life and that's the great risk
of all because you regret that you
didn't take any action yeah but I think
what do you say there it's so true so
you know if you're going to start a new
new biz Rishi then how do you do it in a
way we're not betting the whole of your
life on it and you know we just done
some research with Millennials to say
there's very different kind of segments
of Millennials out there with different
needs and there's some very kind of
different motivations around them but
one common theme is that most of them
expect to be run in and started more
than one business through their life and
actually in Nigeria to this over 16
countries in Nigeria to Mason they
reckon they'll be running five
businesses and starting five new
businesses in their life which is
tremendous and then I kind of think it
comes back to culture of them and I've
always run companies where do words I
use like treat the company's money as if
it's your own and I loved your concept
of bootstrap at a business I and I used
to you know when I've started businesses
or funder businesses I'd say it's really
great to almost run it on fumes for a
while and then kind of build momentum
test drive staff when you know stuff
works for customers are the product or
services then you scale out but you
shouldn't kind of hate this concept I
really honestly hate this concept where
you go raise loads of money have /
offices go flying around the world in
business class and just waste money and
lose the essence of waste on the
business or connection with the
customers
whereas it's much better to have that
culture where you're a street fighter
you're out there you're grappling and
scrap it and you you really focused on
delivering Thea customers and really
making a difference but to Evans point
you're not you know every step of the
journey you're kind of just thinking
about what's the next risk what's the
next it's had away how do I reduce that
risk how do I reduce my exposure but you
still keep that essence of you know a
bootstrap business and even as you grow
your business I'm you know I got a
little case that a really good dumb
coming out in Vancouver actually
peekaboo beans started by Tracy Kosta
back in i'm in 2006 and she was her
passion was actually just amazing play
way for kids and clothes and she stunned
the brand sold it direct and then she
saw the you know cataclysmic change in
terms of buying habits between Main
Street and the web and she kind of moved
our whole business took a big business
bet so changed the whole distribution
channel of all her clothing boutiques in
Vancouver and went direct but while
she's never looked back and what seventy
percent year-on-year growth I think she
employs over 700 am salespeople scalable
model in and they've got 25 employees up
in Richmond I the headquarters but more
importantly she's kept the ethos of
treat the company's money as if it's
your own remember those kind of really
exciting days where we started the
business bring that energy into your
business that you had on day one when
you used to take people down the bar on
a Friday night or you got our keg of
beer into the parking lot and stuff like
that these those are the things that
first of all people remember and
secondly it keeps you true to your
original values